there he goes he's just removing
boxes and boxes of stuff putting it in a
garbage bag and heading for the door
no problem catch you later gang people
on the left were basically like well
this is the cry of the oppressed well
except for how it's not the cry of the
oppressed
it is crime rocketing around the
internet was a video
from a walgreens in san francisco and
for folks who have visited
any of our major cities over the course
of the last few years
there's a pretty obvious uptick in
property crime not just an obvious
uptick in property crime
a complete downturn in quality of life
there's a reason that people have been
fleeing big cities
in favor of more outlying red areas or
blue cities in red states
okay san francisco has been turned from
a gem a very
clean and safe city into something
really quite awful
over the past few years you've seen
reports of feces human feces on nearly
every corner open needles on nearly
every corner
in los angeles the homeless problem is
so unbelievably bad that it has now
invaded the suburbs you have people who
are
mentally ill or drug addicts or
basically sleeping on the curbs
outside people's homes in los angeles
this was happening outside my home in a
fairly nice suburb of los angeles
one of the reasons we moved the same
thing has happened in seattle
used to be called the emerald city now
it's the brown city for all the poop
that is in public
and well one of the things that is
upticked in
the recent years has been obviously
low-level crime now people on the left
like to pretend the low-level crime
isn't actually a crime
it's just the cry of the oppressed right
if somebody is shoplifting it's because
poverty is such an endemic problem in
american capitalistic society
it's not a problem of morality it's not
a problem of decency it's a problem of
poverty
except that when we see film of people
actually engaging in
crime it generally is not people
stealing the necessities of life just to
get by
more often it looks like something like
this so here is the video from
walgreens you're about to see a young
black man i point out his race here
only because as we will see san
francisco has decided that they
do not wish people to know the race of
the people who are engaging in crime
because they want to avoid quote-unquote
stereotyping this ties into the whole
black lives matter argument
that if there is disproportionate arrest
of particular people
that is not because disproportionate
crime is being committed by particular
people
it is because of racism inside the
system in any case
it's a young black man who is at a
walgreens
and he is just literally shoveling stuff
he looks like he is in the uh in the
soap and pharmacy aisle he's literally
just shoveling stuff
into a garbage bag okay and his bike is
right there
his bike is sitting next to him and
you're about to see him shovel stuff
into this bag and then just take off
there he goes he's just removing
boxes and boxes of stuff putting it in a
garbage bag hopping on his bike
and heading for the door you see there's
a security guy there the security guy
sort of
puts out a limp hand to try and grab the
garbage bag nothing
and there he goes just right out the
door no problem catch you later gang
well people on the left were basically
like well this is the cry of the
oppressed if you looked at the blue
checks
on the left on twitter this is the cry
of the oppressed well except for how
it's not the cry of the oppressed
it is crime and crime is generally not
the the
attempt by the left to suggest that
poverty is the great driver of crime
ignores the fact
that there are impoverished places on
earth where people do not engage
in crime at nearly the levels that
people are engaging
in crime property crime in san francisco
for example they're impoverished areas
of the united states where people
are not engaging in this sort of crime
at the same sort of levels
crime tends to be a problem of people
who are
who are committing immoral acts
especially in a prosperous country
like the united states with a robust
social safety net
there's a to to kind of thrust this
off as this is just the downside of the
american system it's just the downside
of the american system
of capitalism of our white supremacist
system
is ridiculous on its face hey here's how
bad the problem has become
in san francisco again one of the most
left-leaning cities in all of america
it's become so bad that 17 walgreens
and this happened at walgreens 17
separate walgreens have closed in san
francisco thanks to the shoplifting
problem
in late may a guy named thomas fuller
wrote in the new york times quote at a
board of supervisors hearing last week
representatives from walgreens said that
thefts at its stores in san francisco
were four times the chains at national
average
and that it had closed 17 stores largely
because the scale of theft had made
business
untenable so the narrative that you hear
from the left of course is this is all
systemic racism and that's the reason
for the crime
and then you see stores like walgreens
and they're not being built in in high
crime low income areas and isn't that
more systemic racism and the answer is
when you allow crime to prevail
stores don't move in they undercut the
tax base they make life worse
people don't have places to go crime is
a terrible thing and if you wish to make
life better for everybody in a community
you have to stop the crime
at its source unfortunately san
francisco and blue cities like it are
not interested in stopping crime at
source they are more interested
in blaming america writ large for their
own unwillingness to stop the crime
that is happening within their borders
employees at walgreens apparently have
been told by the leadership of walgreens
to stand aside
while shoplifting takes place like
you're wondering when you watch that
video
why isn't that security guard doing
something to stop that guy like what's
his job actually it turns out his job is
basically to supervise the shoplifting
because walgreens have been told
walgreens employees have been told by
their supervisors to stand aside because
security officers have been assaulted
repeatedly inside walgreens
now the reason for all of this
particularly with regard to shoplifting
is because of a 2014 california ballot
measure okay that ballot measure
reclassified non-violent theft as a
misdemeanor so
long as the thief took less than 950
bucks worth of material
so you just hit up several walgreens in
a row and you take less than 950 bucks
worth of material and you're fine even
if you get arrested
you'll get off with a slap on the wrist
you'll go right back out on the street
thieves quickly hit on the strategy hit
up a bunch of different stores for less
than 950 bucks worth of stuff
okay then last year amid the black lives
matter protest suggesting again
that all crime in the united states was
truly due to systemic american racism
and that the police were the real
problem amid that
ridiculous notion the city of san
francisco decided to double down on its
soft on crime policies
mayor london breed announced that
booking photos would no longer be
released
lest the prevalence of black and brown
faces among the booking photos lead to
stereotypical
reactions inside stores it shouldn't
want to lead to racial profiling so
instead what we will do is we'll just
obscure
who exactly is committing the crime that
way if a disproportionate number of
black and brown people are arrested
because
a disproportionate number of black and
brown people actually happen to be
committing these sorts of shoplifting
crimes in san francisco
that must mean that the police are
racist you'll never know any different
because we've never seen the booking
photos
in the first place also london breed
announced a 120 million dollar cut to
the police and sheriff's department over
the next two years
in the interest of quote prioritizing
investments in the african-american
community
in the first six months of 2020 alone 23
officers resigned
from the force naturally property crime
has skyrocketed and it's not just
shoplifting
burglaries increased nearly 50 percent
year on year in 2020 in san francisco
car theft jumped 34 in san francisco
meanwhile of course san francisco has
been in a sl uh
a state of slow motion decline for the
past several years the streets are
littered with garbage in 2018
there was a survey of 153 blocks in
downtown san francisco
it showed trash like open trash out on
every single block
41 blocks quote dotted with needles and
96 blocks
of the 153 blocks 96 with open human
feces
and again this sort of stuff is not rare
in major cities around the united states
as i mentioned los angeles the quality
of life has become truly awful
the the slogan for for
the for the herbert hoover campaign in
1932 as a chicken in every pot
the slogan in los angeles is a homeless
person on every bench and presumably on
your driveway as well
and again that is not compassion toward
the homeless treating men
severely mentally ill people and drug
addicts as though they have a right to
sleep on the street and use open needles
in front of your children
is not compassion to either the children
or to the homeless people
san francisco by the way is now facing
its worst drug epidemic ever
according to amy graf of the san
francisco chronicle
she says a physician two nurses a
professional athlete a drug dealer and a
lawyer who had nodded off in court
teenagers specifically a 14 and a 15
year old and a seven-year-old who got
into a stash in her mother's purse
these are some of the types of people dr
christopher caldwell the chief of
emergency medicine at zuckerberg san
francisco general hospital
has recently seen in the emergency room
for medical issues related to fentanyl
use and overdoses a seven-year-old
who got into a stash in her mother's
purse but apparently it's all about
white supremacy gang
caldwell said that's just in the last
couple of weeks it's really remarkable
because it runs the entire spectrum
this affects all walks of life all folks
it's hard to overstate how impactful it
can be to anyone it doesn't seem to care
about race or background or gender
or anything caldwell said on average
about 10 to 15 people who have taken
fentanyl are treated
in the san francisco general emergency
room a day sometimes more
and that's just one hospital in the city
so san francisco
which is famous for being a drug haven
has been for decades
is now experiencing its worst drug
upsurge ever according to the san
francisco chronicle
meanwhile in new york massive
outbreaks on on subway cars of filth and
feces apparently is according to fox new
york
as people return to the subway system in
new york city they are finding more
trash and filth according to a new
report there has been a rise
in soiled train cars this year according
to the daily news including cases of
feces
vomit and blood the paper cited internal
mta reports
an increase in use syringes is being
found amid growing drug use in the
subway system
mta spokesperson andre berman said quote
incidents like this are unfortunate
they're unsanitary for our customers
deeply unfair disturbing for transit
cleaners they're also a reminder of the
need for more mental health outreach and
social service support
in the city and throughout the system
rising crime in the subway system is
also
a problem last month governor andrew
cuomo said people just don't feel safe
riding the trains
they have to feel safe do they feel safe
now no cuomo said at a news conference
the governor said there needed to be
more nypd officers in the subway system
all of which is why according to a new
study from the north american moving
services
the top outbound states for people who
are leaving states in america
illinois new york california new jersey
and maryland
the top inbound states idaho arizona
south carolina tennessee and north
carolina
notice a sort of political theme there
every single
state from which people are leaving is
heavily blue
every single state to which people are
going is red
or purple at best i know what you're
thinking it's time to binge some more
ben shapiro videos well you are right
you should but first like and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video